[Music]
2022 marks 50 years since formal
relations began between australia and
china
but it's an anniversary neither side
seemed to be celebrating
we start with the significant worsening
of relations between china and australia
beijing is waging a politically charged
trade war down under one of china's
government-sponsored scholars described
australian foreign policy as being
bizarre immature belligerent juvenile
and mindless
every time now there is a headline with
australia and china relations we almost
know immediately it's going to be bad
news
a series of disputes between the two
nations has led china to introduce
crippling trade bans on some of
australia's biggest exports
almost a dozen australian commodities
are still subject to official and in
many cases unofficial sanctions by the
chinese government depriving australian
exporters access to billions of dollars
worth of the market
because australia is so closely tied to
china economically it means that china
has a lot of trade leverage over
australia that it can use if australia
does things that it doesn't approve of
you can use the word sanction or you can
use the word trade friction for that but
both of those things refer to the same
point a process of coercion to try and
change australia's political settings
this isn't any old diplomatic row it's
about how the west handles a chinese
government that not only wants to be a
major player in this political game but
wants to decide the rules as well
australia is really the canary in the
coal mine what happens in australia in
relation to china over the next decade
will be a blueprint for how the rest of
the world will handle china in coming
years
[Music]
much of china's economic miracle since
the 1980s has been driven by
industrialization
building roads buildings machinery and
factories all of which requires steel
and to make steel you need two
ingredients iron ore for the iron
content and metallurgical cult provide
the energy in the blast furnace
australia is the world's preeminent
export supplier of both of those
commodities
this was initially the basis for the
relationship starting in the 1980s but
really gathered steam during the
mid-2000s as china's heavier stage of
industrialization took off
australia began to experience what was
known as the mining boom
and the mining boom was a time of
enormous wealth in australia so billions
and billions and billions of dollars of
income flowed into the country and
australia became enormously rich and
comfortable and that mining room was
thanks entirely to china
mineral resources became the foundation
of the relationship
but as china's wealth grew so did its
demand for luxury goods
wine and rock lobster became popular
among china's burgeoning middle and
upper classes which provided australian
exporters even more opportunities and
cemented trade ties
two-way trade grew from
86 million us dollars in the early years
of our diplomatic relations
to
136.4 billion u.s dollars in 2013
and china
has been australia's biggest trading
partner for five consecutive years
australia also developed a number of
other export industries which china was
in need of as its development level rose
are probably the most famous is
international education where tens and
in some cases hundreds of thousands of
chinese students came to australian
universities to study degrees
in 2019 the income raised from chinese
students studying in australia was
valued at around 12 billion australian
dollars
that same year 1.4 million chinese
tourists spent over 12 billion dollars
contributing to more than one quarter of
australia's entire international tourism
spend
but while trade relations have thrived
politically the two nations have kept
their distance
for most of the last 30 years the way
that that circle has been squared is
attempt to keep the two things in
separate discussions we'll have a
discussion about the political where
we'll be able to disagree and have
disputes at times whereas on the
economic we can have a discussion solely
about the economic and where those
mutual benefits lie
the challenge we've had over the last
five years is that kind of firewall
between the two sides has become harder
and harder to sustain as many of those
political difficulties have become
stronger and
stronger is he on the side of the
agencies that keep us safe
or is he on the side of a foreign
government
in 2017 australian labor senator sam
dastiari resigned from parliament after
allegations that he'd received money
from chinese donors affiliated with the
chinese communist party
shortly after former prime minister
malcolm turnbull passed foreign
interference laws that targeted cases of
espionage and require people acting in
the interest of overseas powers to
register and disclose their ties
malcolm turnbull at the time while
professing that the legislation was not
targeted at china said that the
australian people have now stood up in
his introduction for it which echoed
what mao zedong said when he started the
chinese
people's republic modern china was
founded in 1949
with this with these words
john guaranty lie the chinese people
have stood up that was considered very
insulting and pretty much laid out
exactly who this legislation was
designed to target
a lot of chinese australians in the
community who had connections with china
whether it be through trade whether it
would be personal network connections
they felt they were targets of that
foreign interference law ten years ago
or more those connections were really
prized and these people those who had
connections with the mainland whether
through business personal or political
were really valuable for australia-china
relations you know at the end of 2016
people with those kind of connections
were really
seen as vectors of chinese communist
party influence
the foreign interference act came amid
mounting concern about china's influence
over australian politics
what followed were a number of political
disputes that eroded bilateral relations
even further
china's ambassador on the attack
renewing criticism of australia's ban on
huawei preventing the chinese telco from
participating in australia's 5g rollout
as i see it it's basically politically
motivated
china says australia's decision to offer
safe haven to hong kong residents is a
serious violation of international law
today the pm hit back at china's
escalating rhetoric after beijing said
hong kong protesters were showing signs
of terrorism china has rejected
suggestions it's behind a large-scale
cyber attack on australia no one was
ever arguing that there shouldn't be an
independent investigation into the
origins of the virus but it's curious
why did canberra have to take the lead
on this
there's been a number of key points
along the bilateral timeline where we
can sort of pinpoint that spiraling
downward of relationship and then when
australia called for an international
investigation into the origins of the
carolina virus that really put china on
attention we will need an independent
inquiry that looks at what has occurred
here so we can learn the lessons
many i guess on the china site felt like
issues which are difficult to navigate
shouldn't be broadcasted by megaphone
they should be addressed quietly behind
doors
to each engineer
now that inquiry was ultimately
supported and conducted by the world
health assembly in that year but the
chinese government was extremely upset
about australia's going forward and
going first in terms of that
international call and the result was a
series of trade sanctions applied to
nearly a dozen strained commodities over
the latter part of 2020.
in may 2020 an 80 tariff was put on
imports of bali and restrictions were
placed on imports of beef which had
brought in nearly 3 billion for
australian farmers the year before
china announced an investigation into
australian wine imports claiming that
australia was dumping excess wine on the
market eventually that led to tariffs in
excess of 200
being put on australian wine effectively
killing the trade almost entirely
some of these chinese sanctions have
been put on an official map particularly
for barley and wine and coal but in some
other agricultural products they've used
a grey zone tactics so these aren't
official bands but unofficially these
products don't get passed through
chinese customs and therefore can't be
sold in the country and it's very hard
to be able to get traction on them using
international trade law because you
would first have to prove that it's even
occurring
before these recent tariffs were placed
on australia china purchased around a
third of all exports worth more than 150
billion australian dollars
now with restrictions in place some
industries are fare better than others
coal provides an illustrative example as
the effect of that sanction was just a
musical chairs arrangement different
people were selling to different people
but not really any overall loss for any
players in the market an alternate
example would be for some of the
exporters who don't have alternate
viable markets available to them
in most years china would buy over 90 of
australia's rock lobster exports and
having that market shut down overnight
there was not really any other deep
markets in asia where you could place
that many rock lobsters wine suffered a
similar fate as did australian timber
products so the effects ranged from mild
to negligible um to very catastrophic
for other small industries as well
while china is economically critical for
australia the reverse is less true
some 70 of australia's exports are
resources for which there are
alternative suppliers
however there's one australian export
which can equate to up to 10 percent of
the country's gdp and it remains
critical to china
china keeps buying australian iron ore
when he signed that could change oh no
quite frankly china needs it
china is the world's largest buyer of
iron ore not just in asia but in the
world
and australia for its part is the
world's largest exporter of iron ore
about 80 of which goes to china
so when you have the world's largest
buyer and the world's largest seller in
the same region for both sides there's
not really any other alternative
at the height of the trade dispute
between australia and china there were
all these questions about why doesn't
china just get its iron ore from
somewhere else and certainly they've
tried they've tried to get iron ore from
brazil they've tried to get iron ore
from africa but the deposits in africa
aren't developed enough and the ones in
brazil are famously unreliable china
couldn't cut off the iron ore trade with
australia and because of that china's
cursive trade measures could not be as
effective as they would otherwise be
for all the diplomatic bluster and the
trade coercion australia and china were
still held together deep beneath all the
noise and the fury by this
tight link of iron ore
while the iron ore sector kept some form
of trade ties intact the diplomatic side
of the relationship broke down
for two years there were no high-level
discussions between the countries
australia said it tried to reach out to
its minister or counterparts in china
and it just wouldn't get a response
which at some levels is frustrating for
instance on trade relations on foreign
relations and in some cases is dangerous
when it comes to things like defense and
military especially as australia was
still running operations in the south
china sea and in waters not too far away
from china itself so effectively for two
years australia and china didn't have
diplomatic relations at a high level and
that coincided with the rise of wolf
warrior diplomacy in china which meant
that instead of talking there was a lot
of yelling from beijing directed at
australia on the other side however you
then had the morrison government who
were very much hyping up the threat from
china they were talking a lot about the
drums of war beating in asia and
comparing the current times to the late
1930s before world war ii that kind of
strident rhetoric under the previous
government really didn't sit well with
their chinese counterparts in beijing it
didn't give them any sense of space into
navigating those delicate and complex
international issues
but again i think you know china has
some blame to bear in the state of
bilateral relations its issuing of those
14 grievances really puts australia in a
difficult spot
one piece of paper 14 points a
diplomatic shot from beijing and
canberra that's been heard around the
world
in november 2020 a list was leaked to
the australian media allegedly from the
chinese government containing 14
grievances that would need to be
addressed before a trading relationship
could resume
the list included restricting free media
and preventing parliamentarians from
speaking out against china
the problem with the 14 ingredients is
that they put
australia and china in a very difficult
position because australia couldn't do
any of them because if it did them it
would be seen as giving up a lot of its
democracy and its free speech
to appease china and china couldn't get
up on them because they presented them
to australia in the first place it ends
up being a bit of a hole which neither
side could dig themselves out of
[Music]
the chinese ambassador to australia has
since said the 14 points were
misinterpreted
eventually the concerns were being
reported in the twisted way as the
so-called preconditions
as demands
this is a natural that's natural
heightened political rhetoric was
amplified on both sides
the result was a polarization of public
opinion and communities caught in the
crossfire
the consequence of that not being
specific and not being targeted in
talking about
you know what aspects of china are we
talking are we talking about the
government are we talking about the
communist party chinese australians got
caught in that middle of that change and
that reassessment
what happens in that sort of looking top
down
is you miss the granular and the more
complex issues that arise from community
and social side of things and that is
you know discrimination and racism being
perpetrated
because of the state of bilateral
relations
and i think the first and second year of
the being chinese in australia survey
really showed one of that consequences
and that was you know high rates of
discrimination and threats to chinese
australians physical safety
[Applause]
since anthony albanese's labour party
won a national election in may 2022
leaders from both countries have
signaled that they want to ease the
tensions of recent years
since albinisi actually came to power
we've seen a far more subtle shift in
how his government is handling the
relationship with china they seem to be
doing two things at once so on one hand
they are maintaining that line they are
speaking up on human rights on the other
hand they are
very carefully exploring how they can
improve relations with the chinese
government we've seen the first
high-level diplomatic contact between
australia and china in years
but mending relations has not been
without its challenges
a new security deal signed between the
solomon islands and china in april 2022
has officials worried that it could pave
the way for a chinese naval base in the
pacific
it also raised concerns beyond just the
apac region
it was a shock wave to the us and
australia and it meant that they then
rushed back out to the pacific to try
and repair relations that they i guess
hadn't really known were broken in the
first place and so now the pacific has
become an incredibly important part of
the global strategic contest between the
us and china
the regional dynamics have shifted
china has indicated its strategic
ambitions in the indo-pacific and that
really you know complicates a lot of
things for the australia-china relations
i would suspect that you can have
cordial trade relations but disagree on
a lot of other international issues
whether it be security in the
indo-pacific but i guess it all comes
back to you know where can the two
countries find common points of
agreement and work on those and can the
two countries
agree to disagree on various issues what
we've seen recently is the greatest
power shift in modern history across the
pacific from the us to china we no
longer have the comfort of the world
that's dominated by the us with his
values and pretty consistently largely
shared
australia is often described as being on
the front lines of the international
debate over how to handle the rise of
china
the question is whether or not australia
can have a trade relationship with china
again but a strategic relationship
that's far more focused on the us
can australia want different things for
the region that maybe go against what
china wants and still live peacefully
and co-exist with china these are the
questions that are going to be asked for
years to come
[Music]
[Music]
you